hey everybody out there it's the
Christmas themed movie retrospective
show yeah we saw some weird Christmas
movies horror movies yes I love
Christmas horror movies I really do and
I think that we did we did um one last
year's we we did Christmas Chronicles
last year yeah and then we also did that
really I can't even remember the name of
it Christmas evil or whatever it was
called yeah nothing's gonna top
Christmas Chronicles no well yeah we're
gonna cross oh man [ __ ] do if you
guys know such Chronicles go see a [ __ ]
right now it's probably free on Netflix
huh
yeah it's on Netflix though Oh at least
I hope it is because that's my favorite
Christmas movie yeah to the top of the
list right to the [ __ ] top yes the
bone tomahawk accrues you're not I mean
when you understanding crustal and being
part of the crustal sphere and
understanding crustle tude and
everything crystal is mother you
wouldn't think across it would be a good
Santa Claus [ __ ] no he's a [ __ ]
best Santa Claus of all time he is a
really good [ __ ] best Santa Claus
he's like gruff but you know also like
he's a macho Santa Claus he's a high
testosterone I was like and it's a good
story man it's a good story for the hall
so he steals a cop car it's a good story
good story for the whole family's got a
lot of adventurers in it it's got
[ __ ] elves it's got little kids in it
it's kind of Spielberg Ian's in a
certain way back when Spielberg was good
and you know it's just good movie I it's
I like I like the little Elsa yes I'm
wearing I'm unplugged Christmas
Chronicles right here even though we
come every year I will plug
we're gonna watch it to get up on eggnog
eggnog with [ __ ] whiskey and [ __ ] and
Rob Robin off me and crustle
in community yeah enjoying enjoying the
power of Christmas yeah it's not spirit
Christmas is Christmas power Nietzsche
and Christmas yeah that's right yeah
definitely check out Christmas
Chronicles on Netflix like I said we
were beat it on our Christmas
retrospective last year yeah this year
what we decided to do
because you know every um Christmas just
like Netflix does shudder adds like a
handful of Christmas horror movies so we
decided to review the ones that they had
added now I should note that they also
if you guys that have shudder if you've
ever watched um Joe Bob Briggs the last
drive-in um he did a Christmas special
this year it was a triple feature and he
did black Christmas which we're gonna do
he also did Silent Night deadly night to
which we're also gonna do and he also
did Jack Frost which I haven't got
around to watching it but so he's like
reviewed all of them and I've watched
most of them because I love Joe Bob you
know so he does the movie but then like
he breaks in every few minutes and like
tells you like a bunch of facts about
the movie like goes off on like funny
old man rambles and stuff like that and
it's very hilarious there's also a chick
on there who's I can't report her name
is but she has like huge huge tits and
like a little Christmas outfit on and I
think at the end of the Silent Night
Silent Night deadly night - they impaled
her on antlers like not really but just
like in Silent Night deadly night one
but we'll get into that in a minute now
I've been wanting to do a review of
Black Christmas for a really long time
this came out in 1974 Canadian horror
film there is some controversy because
not controversy exactly but I think some
people think okay now if ever anybody
says that Halloween from 1978 like John
Carpenter's Halloween nuts not that's
not an awesome movie but some people say
like oh that's like the first slasher
movie and that is not the case it's
probably the slasher that kind of kicked
off the slasher boom of the 1980s I
wouldn't argue that point but one of the
very early slashers was Black Christmas
like I said it came out in 1974 although
I would argue that probably Mario Baba's
twitch of the death nerve ie or in other
title Bay of blood which came out in
1971 is probably the first movie that
had like what you would recognize as
slasher tropes today some people say Oh
psycho or you know peeping tom you know
from 1960 I can see more I I think more
of a case could be made for peeping tom
was kind of more like a slasher than
psycho psycho was a thriller but like I
said I'm if you're gonna say slasher
like is something you would recognize as
a slasher day I would probably say BAM
flood although there was some Herschell
Gordon Lewis [ __ ] in the 60s - like
blood feast and culinary blood-red and
[ __ ] like that was kind of I don't know
the first time I saw psycho I was a
little kid yes you showed that on TV
cuz you did yeah I think I saw it on
tape you didn't have to edit it yeah cuz
it would pass you know back in the 70s
you know yeah that would pay yeah
there's nothing like really and they had
a minute and they had it on like might
have been like Saturday monster matinee
something like that yeah that's probably
where I saw it and man that that blew me
away
yeah cuz that was the as a kid at that
age you know I'm telling mother this is
even before I saw alien you know alien
was the first really good horror sci-fi
movie but the first good horror movie I
ever saw on TV was psycho yeah what like
well-written oh yeah cuz I'm and it
still holds up yeah cuz because the in
those days the only what I was used to
seeing Edie would type horror movies
that's a hurry is yeah I could see I was
like I would thing like yeah I was just
used to like dumb [ __ ] you don't need a
lot of walking and driving
voiceover the read the old man your
stupid mind your stupid but that was
used to that yeah yeah I mean in this
psycho came on and man it was a real
movie is a real movie oh [ __ ] and then
when the [ __ ] chair turned around
yeah I can I wish that I had like I that
I was born then or like that I was alive
then because it came out in 1960 that
was like 12 years before I was born but
I kind of wish that like by the time I
saw it that it hadn't like you know
penetrated pop culture to such an extent
that like you knew what was coming you
know what I mean I kind of wish I had
eggs alright and I got that experience
cuz I think by the time I saw it I'd
already seen like although that's know
how me I pry something I was like seven
yeah seven or eight and you know that
was that was the first real good horror
movie I saw yeah like a real movie yeah
the rest of his just like kids [ __ ] you
stupid fired stuff ed would type stuff
but yeah so black Christmas even it's
generally considered a Canadian horror
film even though the director of it Bob
Clarke was actually an American he was
from Florida of all places although he
did live in Canada for a very long time
and he didn't make this movie in Canada
now when he made this movie he had
already made uh the cult classic
children shouldn't play with dead things
he had also made yet another cult
classic called death dream which is
actually a very good movie so this was
his third movie now he got the idea
because of its actually from the
babysitter and the man upstairs very
famous urban legend which had been going
around since [ __ ] time immemorial
probably since girls started babysitting
at people's houses um so he like wanted
to make kind of a movie about that now
the original script which I think the
original name of it was something like
stop me or something like that and it
actually wasn't supposed to be senator
or sorority house it was supposed to be
about babysitters because like I said it
was based on the urban legend just like
Halloween was based on the urban legend
just like when a stranger calls was
based on the urban legend but this was
kind of the first one to do something
with that um so when Bob Clark kind of
read the screen he liked the screenplay
but he's like well let's you know I
don't really want the kids in it or any
[ __ ] like that so it's like let's set it
like college age and we'll set it like
you know in a sorority house like older
so the interesting thing was that he got
a really like big deal cast to be in
this [ __ ] movie like somewhat like
the star of the movie is [ __ ] Olivia
Hussey who at the time was like a really
big star I mean she had just been in
Zeffirelli's Romeo and Juliet and she
was known like all over the world and
you know she had been ill she was
generally like in a lot of kind of like
real highbrow type movies and she was
like a London stage actress and all this
other kind of [ __ ] they didn't think
that she would want to do it because it
was just this is like a $600,000 slasher
movie pretty much but they asked her to
do it and she accepted the part because
her psychic had
told her a few days before she got the
script that she was gonna be going to
Canada where she had never been before
and she would make it and she would make
a movie there that would make a lot of
money her psychic older so she took the
bar they just thought that was really
funny that like this big famous star
would be in this movie what if he made a
lot of money um not so much it made it
it made quite a bit like it made
obviously it made much more than its
budget back because it didn't cost that
much to make but it kind of got sort of
mixed reviews at the time it made a lot
of money according to the psychic in
terms where the psychic was used to
making yeah compared to what she's you
making used to make it a lot yeah so
it's like quite a prophecy yeah so the
fact that that Olivia Hussey had like
signed on to do it then they also got um
Kira do Leah who had been in 2001 a
Space Odyssey as Bowman yeah you know
but and he said Olivia has he's gonna be
oh this must be like a [ __ ] high
class yeah production so he said he
would be in it too he plays her kind of
high-strung boyfriend yeah um Margot
Kidder is in this and she is probably my
favorite character there's just
something about that woman is this
[ __ ] boob a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] my
kitten Margo just was came off as just
[ __ ] whenever I saw hers liked it you
know it's a good thing yeah like yeah
we're not saying a bad thing yeah she
was like a [ __ ] Lois Lane there's just
something this is like some there's just
something bad about her well yeah and
she and yeah and I like that too because
she comes across like in probably she
wasn't she was kind of famous at this
point because she this was before
Superman this was before Amityville
Horror she had however been in Brian
DePalma's sisters which if you guys
haven't seen that that's a really really
good movie um so go check that out I
think I saw him for free on YouTube but
her character in this barb she is like
the foul-mouthed drunk sorority sister
here just like tells everyone to [ __ ]
off and it's like she's giving alcohol
to children yeah she's like you know
giving cops the [ __ ] phone number of
I have a feeling though that's kind of
the way
as though she does kind of come crying
that's the way she was and that kind of
came through even in the Superman series
to me yeah that she just came across as
a bad girl even though when you look at
her in the Lois Lane role she's kind of
supposed to be like she's just a New
York chick yeah but by today's standards
even better even really by the standards
of those those days she wasn't doing
anything unusual no it wasn't there was
just something there's an underlying
tone with Margot Kidder yeah you just
porn might break out at any second and I
have to tell you in black Christmas he's
like one of my very favorite scenes in
this because like I said she's my
favorite character by far and like all
of the characters in this is really good
like I'm really likeable and relatable
and stuff but one of my favorite scenes
is when she is there with like the house
mother and a couple other people like
this guy whose daughters gone missing
and she is like completely lit and she
just starts apropos of nothing she just
starts telling the story about these
Turtles [ __ ] at the zoo yeah they can
[ __ ] for three days she says she's at
the zoo like watching them and she's
like and it was very very boring it's
just like and it's a good movie he's got
a lot of good actress is there and odd
acting yeah it's [ __ ] John Saxon is
in this Antonia Martin from sctv who you
know she's done like a ton of [ __ ] since
then although you know what's
interesting and I didn't know this but
the Andrea Martin part that was actually
supposed to be Gilda Radner she was
actually offered the part first and she
took it but then like a month later she
had a drop out because she had you know
some other like a went career
obligations and couldn't do it when I
first saw this I could really see how
Friday the 13th part 1 in many ways was
a copy of this yeah and Halloween's kind
of a copy of it yeah we're trying to set
up a contrived situation like this yeah
for these for for this series of murders
to happen you can really if you like
Friday 13th one and like you said
Halloween you want to see this one too
because it's where that came from if you
ask me yeah
this is kind of like like I said yes you
can make an argument for the Mario Bava
movie like being cuz that's very much
you would recognize a lot of Slater
slasher tropes in that movie I mean even
so much so that Friday the 13th one and
two like directly ripped off a couple of
kills from that like like the spear
through the two people [ __ ] and and
stuff like that that comes right from
those baby-makin
I know that comes right from that Mario
Bava maybe they stole it like you know
unashamedly Kevin Bacon Annette Annette
hottie with the big boobs and the short
shorts got speared right through the
damn [ __ ] bed yeah like I said they
stole that wasn't like father was a
teenager then and I was just like god
damn what a waste
perfectly good pair of titties well yeah
I'm not only been like 13 or so you know
maybe 14 but I I knew you know I thought
you know I was into that [ __ ] well yeah
maybe 14 that I've had for food yeah
damn I was easy to impress back then oh
I think 12 13 14 yeah boys the world
alright yeah yeah but so yes so the
thing about this though even though the
like I said this did a lot of things
that later became tropes like the killer
POV shots you know just this kind of
like Center or sorority house although
interestingly it's not real gory um
no tits as far as I know I don't think
there's no nudity and all like that in a
way it's kind of like it's like an adult
slasher movie if you know what I'm
saying cuz you know how like slasher
movies they usually trying to target
like teenage boys and stuff like that
but it had a lot of the small talk and a
lot of the conversations and it kind of
contrived conversations to fill the
movie out that are entertaining but man
that's all throughout the [ __ ] early
yeah Friday the 13th in the early
slasher movies you I remembered those
conversations a lot growing up you know
you know I mean you could in that funny
they're just that these dumb little
conversations yeah but you'd remember
him for like the rest of your life yeah
I left for a long time well hey they
kind of like had an impact on you well
it's like ever there yeah well cuz the
thing about this one
I mean yeah that happened in a lot of
slasher movies but I think the reason
why it works so well in this one one
because the cast is amazing these are
all like really good actors but also
they're not
none of them are annoying yeah um they
all seem I mean to me they all seem like
real people even nowadays like when they
make slasher movies nowadays I feel like
everybody is like an Instagram model
being in a movie if you know what I'm
saying this was like very much just real
just regular people you know they
weren't like oh I'm so hot in here look
at my nipples and everything like you
know it as you would if you sent in a
sorority house nowadays yeah um you know
what I mean just as a gratuitous kind of
like look how sexy we all are these just
are very I mean they're attractive girls
but they're just act they're just
regular people it's a 70s movie yes
that's just done in a 70s way but you
saw that in the early 80s too just
didn't have a lot of the corn it had its
own kind of corniness it did have a
corny tone to it sometimes but it's not
like 90s corny yeah and it's not as
really like it has humor in it it's just
a different way of doing it but I don't
find the humor particularly over-the-top
or you know I I don't find it
particularly corny well didn't you
didn't require as much to be remembered
back then you they weren't all competing
to try to stand out on top one another
it was so that productions themselves
and the scripts are a little bit more
laid-back really yeah and naturalistic
yeah but that's a good word because
that's this is a very like naturalistic
yeah slasher movie it's like something
that really happened yeah and another
interesting thing too is that and one
thing that I think kind of contributes
to you know why it's so good and why
it's so fondly remembered is that you
never see the killer the killer does not
get a backstory um you know he's a miss
he's a mystery he's just been up in the
attic and he's just been calling them
and all this other kind of [ __ ] and you
kind of you hear the obscene phone calls
like with all this ranting and you kind
of like a you know something about Billy
which is usually what they call the
killer and you know that director Bob
Clark said that he had a backstory for
the killer but he didn't reveal any of
it he's so he just had like all this
ranting Finn if I were to say this movie
had a week
it would be that see I like that I think
I think well this is before the slasher
movie had totally [ __ ] crystallized
there the the the killer kind of becomes
condensed into some kind of like you
said a symbol where it with with Jason
is that mask yeah with you know the guy
from [ __ ] what you call it he's got
the [ __ ] Kirk mask on
yeah from Halloween Halloween so each
Connor each each franchise the killer
had a gimmick yeah had his own identity
this one does it like you said he's kind
of a faceless all you see is his I
pretty much like his silhouette right at
his hands I think it did need something
though in need that character needed
more fleshing out I'm just saying yeah
see I don't agree I think it's creepier
when because you get a sense of the
person's character because like I said
they they're obviously like have some
kind of like multiple personality type
disorder because they're doing all these
different voices like when they call and
the [ __ ] that he says on the phone
kind of like hints at a backstory and
like hints at this person's you know
craziness but I like that they never
show him they don't really give him like
a motivation other than he's just a nut
and that he's kind of up there you never
see him and another thing to then this
is a spoiler alert if you haven't seen
this movie but the end of it they leave
the ending ambiguous because it you know
in a later
you know slasher movie Olivia Hussey
hussies character Jess would be the
final girl and she would be and they do
have a little bit of that like it then
where she kind of like fights him and
stuff but then at the end the killer
doesn't get caught yeah she like her
boyfriend who is kind of like they have
like a little bit of a red herring where
you think it might be him because he
kind of goes off because you know she's
pregnant and she wants to get an
abortion and he doesn't want her get one
and there's like this big argument about
it and then so she ends up like thinking
that he's the killer because he comes in
the house and she ends up beating him to
death and then they think oh well it was
him all along but the killer is real
still in the house and then they leave
her in there by herself and then that's
where it ends like they leave it
ambiguously that's an open for a sequel
yeah there wasn't a sequel but if there
was a sequel it would have been
something like along the lines of maniac
yeah remember the movie maniac because
it was a similar kind of a bad guy
although I think maniac did a better job
of letting me know with what he was like
yeah well yeah they kind of spent a lot
of time what there's been a lot of time
with the killer I think maybe had they
done a little bit he they said he they
planned on giving him a little bit of
backstory had he had you got a little
bit of maniac action I think that I
think I'd like to move well the part I
think the production company wanted Bob
Clark to definitively show who the
killer was and all this other kind said
but he didn't want to do that he wanted
to leave it and like I said in a way I
liked that better because you know I
love slasher movies I love the Friday
the 13th movies I love Halloween I love
all of those but I do feel like when the
focus shifts to the killer and it makes
the killer like a character or like an
icon then you kind of like it comes a
point where you know it's like the later
Friday the 13th ones it's like you don't
give a [ __ ] about people that are in it
you just want to see them get killed
yeah whereas in this one the focus is
more on the girls and what they're going
through and their characters their
personalities and so I like that better
you're probably right
I think I'm to me that goes a creepier
had you given him more screen time and
like say put a mask on him you basically
just would have had a high-caliber [ __ ]
the Friday the 13th cuz here's the thing
this could be a Friday the 13th movie
yeah in a way yeah could be like the
Friday the 13th prequel you could say it
like that
it could be yeah you know in but I think
fri 13th is a little more graphic but
still yeah although not as graphic as i
remembered well like when I forgive
everyone backs off right 13 yeah no
don't see that much yeah it's like they
made a big deal like we got the blu-ray
it's like who unrated and I'm just like
okay I remember it being a lot greater
than yeah when you're a kid you know
that means suggestion is enough I guess
silent and seeing a little bit was
enough you got to be remember I was
watching it you know but then I mean
this one like
I said this one's not really really gory
or anything like that but it's got like
some really great like I just love that
atmosphere of it like she's all the
Christmas lights it's all this warm
light and um you know I love some of the
like iconic image like of the dead girl
that's like up in the attic the whole
time like with the plastic around her
and like in the rocking chair and they
never find her and like they keep like
showing it like you know what I mean
they're looking everywhere for this girl
and she's just like up in the attic the
whole time and it's like just really
creepy yeah yeah yeah and it does kind
of have that look to us and Italian
flair to it you could tell that they
were they were influenced by Italian
horror movie yeah they probably were
because a lot of the kind of the
lighting and the set pieces horror
cinema yeah not even the film I'm here
on out what I'm talking good about
someone called cinema well yeah yeah
classy classy its classy that's right
it's a fit like I said it's a film with
capital F yeah now the thing about this
this came out and initially like it was
released in Canada first like around
Halloween time but then in the u.s. they
release it around Christmas time in 1974
but in the u.s. at first when they first
released it they called it silent night
evil night because the producers thought
that if they called it black Christmas
everyone think it was a blaxploitation
movie it's the title of it but then they
when they Bri released it later they
changed it to the regular name another
thing too that I thought was very
interesting was that a will in a
horrifying way was that they were
actually going to show this on TV under
the title stranger in the house however
two weeks before it was scheduled to air
Ted Bundy broke into that sorority house
and killed those two girls and assaulted
this two or three other girls and so
after that happened they didn't know it
was Ted Bundy at the time they found out
later but because this movie is also set
in her sorority house and has a crazy
person like killing people in a sorority
house they're like hey can we not show
the movie there was another movie our
members quit it called when a stranger
quite a stranger calls yeah I met with
Carol Kane yeah that was also that was
very straightforwardly based on that on
the
in legend about um you know [ __ ] like
that but I remember seeing that one I
think that one cause kind of stirred me
I really like that maybe actually maybe
we should review that one at some point
but I haven't seen it in a long time but
I remember really liking it um I mean I
think the reason that so many movies
have been made from that particular
urban legend is because that's an urban
legend that a lot of people can [ __ ]
relate to I mean you know you're in the
house by yourself like either you're
babysitting or whatever and like some
creep keeps calling you I'm out of the
three movies that we're talking about
tonight I actually kind of like this one
the best at well this is easily the best
one this is the one you actually kind of
want to see as a priority the other two
are kind of optional I think yeah I mean
if it really this is one that I mean
this is a classic Christmas cry she'd
have done a whole scene you know we can
just like that she talked about it for a
half-hour he's in a bad mood cuz on a
bad mood he just came back from the eye
doctor like his eyes are still messed up
um I think the only other thing I wanted
to say about this was that another
interesting thing that this does one
this is like pretty um it seems like
pretty progressive for the time cuz it's
got Olivia hussies character and she's
pregnant and she's like not wanting the
baby and she's very matter-of-fact about
yeah I don't want to keep it and her
boyfriends like flipping out about it
but she's just very calm and they don't
judge her or anything like that for it
um you know which I thought was kind of
cool another thing that slasher movies
did later that this one didn't do
because you know how the final girl is
always like the most virginal one that's
kind of like the the trope that's not
what happens in this one the virgin gets
off she's the first victim so it's like
you know everybody gets killed pretty
much except for Olivia Hussey and maybe
she gets killed cuz the endings
ambiguous but um you know if this was a
regular horror movie barb Margot Kidder
character would be the first one to get
the axe and she's a long time but she
hangs in there for quite a long time the
virgin is the first one to go she goes
like in the first ten minutes which is
something that they you know did you
know that it's kind of like a subversion
before the troop even came about you
know yeah there's also something about
this
kind of reminds you a little bit like
like like a damn there's a Canadian
director David Cronenberg
yeah well this has a lot of extra lot of
Cronenberg II and the guy that plays
this the the virgin girl our quality
though yes they just kind of say nothing
you know I like Cronenberg yeah then
later stuff and it got better some of
the early Cronenberg was it looked kind
of low quality but this is like very
like high quality Cronenberg so yeah
certain s with an Italian flair to it
this is actually a nice-looking movie
yeah and they did a lot of [ __ ] in this
movie like I said the killer POV cam
which was they weren't the first movie
to do it but it was one of the first you
know few to do it and they didn't have
Steadicam so what they had to do like
the guy who was like the camera man he
had to like build a rig so he would have
the camera like on his head like it was
mounted on his head and he could like do
it like that so he could because there's
a shot where the killer's like climbing
up the outside of the sorority houses no
one else's kind of reminds me of which I
like totally in the way it's shot the
quality of me was kind of like the hand
it was a little bit kind of like oh yeah
that was Oliver Stone did hand when it I
think that was one of his very it's a
high quality movie it's yeah it was in
the genre of of a real good director of
the times yeah not a cheap movie and the
thing about I mean like I said this was
made for maybe $600,000 16 or 20
thousand did a good job um Bob Clark had
like I said he'd made two movies before
this which are kind of like cult
classics
he kind of was all over the map like he
made the very famous a Christmas story
you know you should sheera out
he also made Porky's which was I think
was his most financially successful
movie and then he also made like some
shitty ones too like he made Rhinestone
you remember that movie with Mike and
sly and [ __ ] Dolly Parton in that I
think so yeah he made that movie the
cash man flick it was yes so he kind of
had like a very bizarre career I
actually think Rhinestone made money it
probably the time that was I remember
when that came out a lot of a lot of
women wanted to go see that one yeah
because the cast and that was really
cool at the time but I want to get I'm
gonna get good and give a shout out to
the hand to get if you guys haven't seen
the hand with Michael Caine go watch
that [ __ ] yeah I think damn that
[ __ ]
goddamn Michael Caine
don't be scared the crap looks at you I
know he looks at you he looks at the
camera and then he looks at you and then
he looks at the camera and he looks at
you looks at you then looks over there
then looks over there and you that dude
is like I that dude is like a couple
drinks away a [ __ ] slap and a [ __ ]
out of you well yeah you tell me what
you want
people talk about toxic masculinity and
[ __ ] on YouTube talk about toxic meant
they don't know [ __ ] toxic
masculinity is go watch the hand the
[ __ ] hand and the hand had some
paranormal elements to it
imagine toxic masculinity with the
paranormal yeah yeah paranormal
paranormal taxi get your ass with the
[ __ ] powers of the mind yeah yeah um
Oh another thing I want to quit hand
down on you putting at hand
it's like the pan pan yes yeah except
just seven on it's on song had a psychic
abilities another dark psychic ability
another thing I wanted to mention about
black Christmas that I forgot to mention
is that Barb Margo kiddos key character
is not the only drunk in this movie
there's also the house mother mrs. Mac
yeah who was I guess she was supposed to
be like a vaudevillian dancer like back
in the old days but now she's like an
old lady
and she has like little bottles of
sherry like stashed all over the place
she's just like constantly sloshed and
she is delightful generation I love her
generational alcohol abuse old school
[ __ ] that they hid it in the news
newfangled [ __ ] where they just walk
around [ __ ] you without a bra just
right in your face [ __ ] drinking
talking about turtle [ __ ] you talking
about turtle don't [ __ ] it well it was
Turtles [ __ ] each other it was fine
it wasn't in her species there's no
challenge they can't run when you put it
that way but yeah one last thing I was
gonna say about Bob Clark and this is
kind of sad I actually didn't know this
until I was watching the Joe Bob version
of black Christmas that's on shudder
actually Bob Clark and his 21 year old
son were killed in a car accident they
were hit by a drunk driver like a few
years ago
that shitty yeah but yeah I didn't know
that until I was watching Joe Bob and
I'm like gee thanks Joe for sure yeah
for Christmas talking about black
Christmas but yeah if you haven't seen
1974's black christmas like i said you
will recognize so many slasher tropes
that came about later you can see where
John Carpenter got inspired to do
Halloween because this is kind of like
similar there's even like an urban
legend I don't think this is true but
that John Carpenter got the idea to do
Halloween when he was talking to Bob
Clark about what a sequel to Black
Christmas would be like yeah which you
can see how that would happen cuz like I
said the movies themes are very similar
but I'm not sure if that's entirely the
case or not because like you know Bob
Clark liked to talk [ __ ] up a little bit
alright so like like we said of the
three we're talking about that's easily
the best one it's a classic everybody
should see it now the second one we're
watching this has a very interesting
history and I was kind of like reading
about this this is called dial code
Santa Claus or in the original French
three six one five code Pere Noel this
is a very strange movie this it also
goes by a bunch of other names deadly
games game over hide in freak this came
out in 1989 do you know what this
reminds me of though what okay
this is kind of like the Christmas the
French Christmas version of Extro it
kind of there's some of it yeah how
wacky and [ __ ] far-out Extro is it
kind of reminds me of that this is
definitely a kind of movie where you
have a limited budget but they're trying
to do as much as they possibly can with
that budget yeah it's not a poorly
executed movie it's it's pretty well
done but I could you could tell you
could tell that it's trying to do more
than it can kind of afford to do but
totally it works it's not a real super
serious movie it's it's very much kind
of like like a 80s horror comedy
adventure kind of a thing yeah so hey so
you can really cut it a lot of slack
because it's not supposed to be realism
I will note that
this movie came out in 1989 now it
didn't get like it got a fairly large
release in France however it just it did
pretty well I think and then it did but
then it kind of like slipped between the
cracks like it kind of got lost what
ended up happening with this because the
the premise of this movie is very very
similar to home alone
however this came out this finished
shooting two years before home alone
came out and in fact the director of
this Rene manzoor was actually going to
sue the makers of ohm alone because he
said this is like a ripoff of his movie
which if you watch it in my view it kind
of is I mean it's pretty much as similar
yes it's christmas-themed but other than
that it's pretty much the same although
you know it would also be kind it'd also
be kind of simple to fall into into that
premise accidentally - that's true it
could be just a coincidence why be I
don't know what house lawsuit but well
the thing about I don't think he ever
did that but the but the thing about it
was after home alone came out was such a
huge hit so this movie never got
released in the US because everybody
said oh well everyone would just think
of as a home alone ripoff even though it
came out first in France this is
basically about Hollywood dudes did rip
[ __ ] off that's what I mean it's like
I'm not accusing anyone of burping
anything and maybe it was just a
coincidence but the story is very very
similar a lot of stories have been told
so it's real easy to accidentally tell
the same story as somebody else and
Holly was running out of ideas
some movies are just like some of these
80s movies actually you can go back and
there were movies in the 20s and 30s
that were real similar to that yeah
whether or not they actually went back
and saw that old movie and decided to
remake it maybe not well and so what
happens to sometimes and I've had this
happen to me also is that sometimes
you'll see a movie or read a book like a
long time ago look when you were a kid
and then like 20 years later you'll
think of a story idea or something like
that
and you used and then you use that
without realizing that you were just
like remembering something that you saw
a long time ago I've had it happen
before too because like sometimes I've
written a story and then like I see some
movie and sometimes like no maybe
that's right I got the idea from till I
got around but yeah so the premise of
this movie is there's this little boy
named Thomas and I guess his dad is dead
so he lives with his mom Julie who is
like super super rich I guess she's like
owns a department store I think it's
called print saw and so she is like kind
of a workaholic type of thing so he
lives in this humongous like mansion
like a big fairytale mansion with his
mom and his grandpa and his dog and he
um he's super into like action movies so
like the first part of the movie is like
this little kid like oiling up and like
putting this Rambo [ __ ] on his face and
like this [ __ ] and he's got and he
goes like through this big huge house
like with his dog with his you know
pretend like bow and arrow like it's
like pretend it's like the [ __ ]
jungle and [ __ ] and he's like he's got
like traps like made all over the house
and everything so it turns out that on
Christmas Eve his workaholic mom I mean
she's not like portrayed as negatively
or anything but it's like she's not home
on Christmas Eve because she's working
at the department store and um
what ends up happening is this is this
kid he's supposed to be I think he's
nine or ten and he still believes in
Santa Claus so he starts talking to what
he thinks is the real Santa Claus over
um I guess in Canada and in a couple of
US states they had this - it was called
minitel it's almost kind of like a proto
internet type of thing it was kind of
like copy serve came about later on but
it's a similar thing where you could
like talk to businesses and like talk to
other people like online and they were
like little it was like almost like
little ATM machines and [ __ ] like that
like in malls and whatnot so he starts
talking to someone that he thinks is the
real Santa Claus over this Minitel thing
but it turns out that it's this
psychopath who has just been fired as of
Santa by his mom from the you know from
the department store for slapping a kid
because the kid said I you're not the
real Santa Claus and he was like pow and
like he got fired so he decides that
he's gonna go to this [ __ ] house
where the kid is there with his like
feeble old grandpa who's like half blind
and everything and he's gonna go there
and like murder the [ __ ] out of
everybody so he goes to this play he
dresses up a Santa he goes to this huge
and he kills I think he kills like the
groundskeeper the people that are like
look after the house you know they like
live outside then he kills the dog and I
was like in a very shocking scene like a
you know what I mean because like Thomas
is like underneath and he sees and he
thinks this is a real sand at the whole
time
he thinks Santa is mad at him because he
was going to stay up to see him because
he's like set up all these cameras
around the house and [ __ ] kind of like
in Christmas Chronicles actually no
thinking about it and so he thinks the
whole time that all of this mayhem is
going on he thinks that real Santa is
mad at him because he so Santa like
stabs the [ __ ] dog like right infront
and I was like holy crap that's like
that like ring me out and so then pretty
much the whole rest of the movie is kind
of a cat and mouse in this big huge
house of light and this little kid like
trying to like do traps and stuff just
like in home alone and trying to like
protect his grandpa from this murderous
like most of its indoors yeah yeah it's
just really interesting to me so like I
said this movie had been lost for such a
really long time and then they found it
and I guess it had like some fans as
like pretty much every obscure movie
does and the fans kind of got together
with this production company and they
did a restoration of the movie and then
last year like last Christmas it made
the rounds of like Alamo Drafthouse and
stuff like that is like you know a new
lot like a Lost cult classic Christmas
movie
so then shudder just got it like a few
weeks ago so like I said it's a really
interesting kind of time capsule of that
you know of that time and it's
interesting how it came out before home
alone and yet it's not exactly like home
alone but in the sense that here's a kid
he's by doing all these traps and stuff
and trying to catch the tone is a lot
different it is yeah it's more like a
horror movie it's yeah it's less funny
yeah and it had and it has cuts like a
zany horror movie in a way in the same
way that to me extra member extra yeah
that's that always kind of had like it's
like a zany extraterrestrial horror
movie yeah about aliens that's a [ __ ]
weird ass we need to review that one of
these days we keep talking about it
stro so long we saw it a few years ago
because remember I had never seen it and
you recommended it and I think we saw it
on I think it was free on YouTube yeah
it might still be so we should actually
probably because I think that's one that
a lot of people haven't seen and that is
a bizarre ass movie I worked like a big
long thing about it for my blog a couple
years ago like when we saw it but yeah
so if you have shutter check out this
movie like I said it goes under a lot of
titles I think on shutter they have it
under deadly games or you know dial code
Santa Claus or whatever it is but you
know what I mean if you just like do a
search for it you'll find it it was
actually like much better than I was
expecting that the guy that plays Santa
is actually super creepy so he does like
a really good job alright so the last
movie that we're going to talk about on
this Christmas retrospective is the
infamous Silent Night deadly night part
2 yeah the reason real stink but it's
definitely so bad it's good yeah you can
drink and watch the movies it's
hilarious and here's okay now what a lot
of people might might or might not know
I'm not really sure this but the scene
where the actor the main actor that's in
it Eric Freeman who really kind of
elevates this to you know shitty with
2ds like like I said so bad it's a good
territory because you just like with
this [ __ ] movie
they over over played the [ __ ] out of it
and I think that if he hadn't done that
this probably would've been forgotten oh
you couldn't do this movie in a serious
tone in the way like you know these are
people with film equipment and film
experience making a [ __ ] crazy ass
movie they know it's [ __ ] crazy yeah
they're doing they're going over the top
to add there's an interesting story
behind this one as well did that's how
they played their cards correctly yeah
and they try to just pack as much
entertaining [ __ ] as possibly can in
every second of this [ __ ] movie now
the movies is [ __ ] stinker okay get
away but the main thing that make light
but that's maybe that's not that's not
fair cuz you know what makes a movie a
real stinkers just boredom yeah there's
nothing boring about the movie oh no you
know nothing boring this is wildly
entertaining
it's it's not [ __ ] technically
sophisticated it's not [ __ ] high-tech
it's not I guess it's not even really
well-written but it doesn't have to be
because that's not what they're going
for
it's just imagining your friends get
some cameras and they just make a
[ __ ] craziest movies that they can
with real people out in public you can
tell they're doing this [ __ ] out of
public like in front of the streets out
in the street with their own cars yeah
you know so it seems like well what
ended up happening with this okay and
like I said I think this has kind of
become a cult classic maybe even you
know for people that don't know what
movie it's from because the one very
famous scene with Eric Freeman's
character whose name is Ricky where he's
like just shooting random people in the
street and he goes garbage day and she'd
say that's a meme and that's like a
really famous meme like even people that
don't even know what movie that it's
from have passed that meme around so
that dude is famous because of that
alone now what ended up happening with
this movie
the first Silent Night deadly night was
actually kind of a surprise hit but what
ended up happening with it was that it
came out the same day as a Nightmare on
Elm Street okay now for awhile like the
first weekend that it came out I believe
it was out doing Nightmare and I'm sure
like it was making more money so it was
getting like all this kind of feed but
like a lot of people were really into it
and then after two weeks for some reason
they decided to pull it because people
were getting offended because it's like
you know a Christmas movie it's like
Santa going around like axing people to
death and like murders and people were
like offended so they started pulling it
from theaters so apparently the
producers were mad and they thought well
you know we could have made more I mean
it made money like on video and [ __ ]
like that
so what ended up happening was that the
production company in 1987 said okay
well we're gonna make a sequel to this
and they were still kind of mad that
they had lost some revenue because he
got pulled from the theaters yes so they
asked so they told the editor he wasn't
even a movie director he never directed
a movie before he was an editor and he
said take the first movie
and re-edit it into a new movie yeah and
we will call it a sequel yeah because
they wanted to do it for nothing
yeah okay now so figured nobody had
really seen it but yeah I guess they did
that yeah so the guy he like kind of
tries to he's like look this is just not
gonna work out you guys so he's like can
you please just give us I've heard
either give us a hundred thousand
dollars or two hundred fifty thousand
dollars something like that and give us
like a week or ten days so we can at
least shoot some new footage and then
put it in with the old one so what ended
up happening was they shot about 45 50
minutes of new footage if it took 40
minutes the footage from the first movie
and put it in there like as a flashback
so the whole - the whole first movie
about Billy like in the convent and the
Mother Superior and him becoming a Santa
and killing all those people most of
that is in there including the very
famous Linnea Quigley scene where she
gets stabbed through the tits like but
the antlers and everything which again
that's a very famous iconic shot - she I
think she did that in pretty much all of
her I actually um many years ago I went
to yeah many years ago I went to a
horror convention I met her like linea
Quigley and she's I guess she's awesome
chick she looked like almost exactly the
same older but yes working she did yeah
so I so I will say I'm not saying that
you shouldn't see like if you're gonna
watch Silent Night deadly night part two
you don't necessarily have to have seen
the first one because all the best [ __ ]
from the first one is in the second what
- so what they're doing is they're kind
of like the framing story with the new
guy Eric Freeman who just like over acts
the [ __ ] out of it in just such a
wonderful way and he just goes around
like making the best [ __ ] grimace he
faces and I'll say it's just it's it's
fantastic it's fantastic and so the
frame story is that he is apparently
followed in his murderous brother
Billy's footsteps and he has also kind
of gone off this is kind of less a
Christmas movie because he doesn't
really get into a Santa suit until all
like almost the end but so he's
telling his story he tells Billy's story
first to this psychiatrist because he's
apparently in a mental hospital or
whatever so the first 40 minutes is you
know retelling the first movie like
they're showing scenes from that and
then the second half is like him telling
about his murder spree because
apparently he was [ __ ] up by the
Mother Superior and all that other kind
of [ __ ] as well and they both have this
thing where cuz Santa shot their dad and
like then tried to rape their mom and
then you know cut her throat so now
they're triggered by anything having to
do with like Santa Claus or anything
like that
now the hilarious thing about this is
that so Ricky when he was a kid they
explained it's like well he had like
Christmas trauma so the nuns at the
Catholic orphanage where he was they
said well let's adopt him out to a
Jewish family and then you won't have to
like deal with [ __ ] but of course you
know Christmas is ubiquitous and you
can't kind of but uh but yeah so then it
kind of just like goes into his [ __ ]
that's weird water spray that's kind of
weird how they just said let's take the
first movie and really why did they
think that that was gonna work it's like
a it's like you know yes you can do
different thing like it would be
different if there was like a [ __ ] ton
of like footage they hadn't used um but
troll 2 skipped the whole process of the
first movie there was no troll 1 they
yeah troll 2 yeah well that was a lot of
it maybe there was might have been an
advantage to just calling it troll 2 as
opposed to troll one it was some kind of
statistical thing they were going for
well you know woah cuz wasn't the guy
that made that was Italian right yeah
that was something that a lot of Italian
kind of like those cheap-jack filmmakers
used to do they would make a movie and
then they would say that it was a sequel
to some like big American movie but yeah
even though it didn't have anything to
do with that yeah so I that movie didn't
exist some right there was no troll I
mean there have been movies called troll
but not anything to do when I need to do
with that with that movie he's come up
with troll - that's the name of my movie
well what was troll -
you know how well you do a troll one
either whether troll one yeah the troll
two kind of [ __ ] is that vent
maybe it's troll squared [ __ ] is so bad
that your [ __ ] is so bad that to give it
any kind of credibility have to claim it
was a sequel to another movie yeah it's
like you're pulling something out of
nothing and you're animating you're
pulling something out of nothing in a
certain way yeah we're claiming that
you're not pulling something out of
nothing like though this movie isn't
coming out of nowhere yeah there was a
part one like that well weird way of
looking you could say I mean you could
say that you know there was a part one
and then it got lost like it's a lost
maybe then why would you publicly sell
it as a part to see there's no I mean
yes logic into something about like
trying to so let's take our old movie
and we added it into another movie
though and no one will know never know
yeah it's like well you know the thing
about it is that like I said it's yes it
was like a cheap Jack kind of move but I
actually this movie is terrible but it's
also like a lot of fun and I think most
of it is a lot of fun because of Eric
Freeman's character do you know that
after this movie came out he actually
kind of went into hiding and when that
meme that garbage day meme like went
crazy like on the Internet and [ __ ] like
there was like this big thing where like
people were trying to find him cuz they
couldn't find out where a gun and they
were like looking for him you know what
I mean cuz they thought that he had gone
into hiding cuz the movie was so bad
they finally did like they finally did
find him and he was talking about and he
said well here's the thing he's like we
only had a couple days to shoot this
they shot it on location you know what I
mean and he's like they didn't really
know what they were going for it was you
know they didn't have a lot of money and
he had only been in I don't even know if
he was in any movies before this like he
didn't have a lot of acting experience
he's like the first time that he did
that garbage day line he's like I
actually did it real deadpan like Clint
Eastwood or something like that but he's
like from the sidelines like the
producers tougher stupid crazier crazier
they kept like telling him to be crazier
and crazier so when you see the movie
now he's just like completely over the
top
and it's like just these [ __ ] he just
makes these great like [ __ ] frowny
ass faces I saw some other reviewer like
call him grumpy cat like he doesn't like
a grumpy cat kind of face in this but
it's just like oh it's so [ __ ] funny
and it's like some of the kills in this
are great like this one [ __ ] dude he
comes out like before he's even Santa
Claus he's just like working in a
kitchen or something and he comes out to
this alley and there's some guy that's
like trying to you know collect some
money from this other like small-time
hood or something like that and he gets
mad because any time he sees like
somebody bullying somebody or somebody
like sexually assaulting somebody that
like triggers him because that happened
to him and he's when he was a kid or his
parents and so he's always like naughty
and then like he'll go after you so he
takes this like small-time hoodlum stabs
him through the gut with an umbrella
like all the way through and then opens
the umbrella up and they like the body
blade the body falls like this bloody
umbrella sitting there that starts to
break it's like [ __ ] it's so [ __ ]
great and it's just like and there's you
know there's a scene in the movie
theater this great it's like he kills
like his girlfriend's like ex-boyfriend
by like he's like fixing his car and
he's being a douche or whatever and then
he just like takes the [ __ ] jumper
cables and like puts him in his mouth
and like it was this [ __ ] eyeballs
yeah it's just like it's super super fun
and like I said Eric Freeman if you're
out there it's like he made this [ __ ]
movie just you know what I mean it's
like the poor guy he probably didn't he
probably will never live this down but
it's hilarious it's like it's hilarious
and I feel like there's really something
to be said and you know it's kind of the
same thing that happened with troll 2
where it's like obviously it's a
terrible shitty movie but not really
because it's still really entertaining
and this one is - they have cult
followings for troll - I've never seen
troll - yeah I've seen it yeah it's
gonna find it it's anybody wants to send
us a copy at role - see it's almost like
it's such a weird movie to me because
it's like did aliens make this I mean
you know what I mean is I just I
sometimes I see movies like that and I'm
just like what a human did not make this
movie how did a human make this movie
like some garden it's very proud of that
movie
I guess like some of the lines in this
movie I'm like what the [ __ ] a lot of a
lot of the cast is you know very old now
you know they don't make movies anymore
yeah they're just a little more welfare
up in huh well that one woman that was
in it was like she went mental the main
guy that's in it who was like what are
you like a dentist yeah he's making
money um we watch slow control to live
when we watch the documentary about it
which is called best worst movie which
is really good documentary and um I at
first I kind of liked him even though
he's kind of like one of those you know
aw shucks type of dude yeah he's like
he's kind of a bible thumpers but yeah
but like the more that that it went on
especially when he started going to the
horror convention veges and he started
like [ __ ] none all the like horror fans
like he'd all these weirdos and all and
I was like oh he's dying what kind of
place is this
yeah then I kind of oh these are people
are weird man oh yeah it's like I'm like
what [ __ ] rock if you mean yeah his
people just wearing like you know
dressed up like Santa bites or whatever
yeah fans just like a regular oh my god
he's a Mormon I think any he might be I
think he just seemed yeah he seemed very
very you got shell sheltered and
judgmental I'm doing dude you're into
Horicon trying to sell your [ __ ] and
then he's talking to the people next
turn the boots next oh I was a troll -
you're a troll - you don't know troll -
and they're like gon know and it might
be like sid haig yes probably he was
like super obnoxious like I said he
seemed likable at the beginning but the
longer the documentary went on it was
like yeah very uncool yeah it's like and
not like even embarrassed about that
like he was just not embarrassed about
creation yeah he was just like that like
he was really judging and I hate people
like that but yeah so definitely check
out silent identity - like I said it's
an infamous sequel for a reason yes it
uses 40 minutes of footage from the
first one so you can like pretty much
skinny I don't worry one for I've never
seen the footage I saw the second well I
thought the first how long I was just
gonna have a good time that's why I like
when I saw the Linnea quigley scene I
was like wait that was in the first one
and then when I looked at him I'm like
oh yeah that's why kind of like you know
if you ever want to see one of those old
[ __ ] [ __ ] ninja movies that were
made with a [ __ ] shoestring budget
they're [ __ ] funny they're not good
movies but they're [ __ ] funny ninja
and karate movies and yeah it's like
that they did that a lot with those kind
of movies too like yeah they just like
recut they stole scenes from yeah it is
a three room in there yeah it continuity
what's that just a flash of a bunch of
images yeah [ __ ] yeah uh-oh I have to
mention - it's like cuz this was driving
me crazy the whole time I was watching
Silent Night deadly night - and these I
think these were all scenes from the
first movie
the the woman that plays the Mother
Superior in the first movie because they
had to get a different actress for the
second one in the first movie the whole
time I was watching I was like god damn
it where have I seen that woman I was
like I've seen that actress somewhere
and I said I've seen her in something
that I've seen a bunch of times because
I kept recognizing her voice in her face
and everything I'm like who the [ __ ] is
that
and so I looked her up and she was like
she was in a [ __ ] ton of stuff she was
like a stage actress and all these
movies I didn't recognize any of the
movies though I'm like I don't it's like
I saw those but I only once and I don't
really remember it you know where I
remembered her from [ __ ] blood lust
which was on MST that's why it's because
the dude from [ __ ] Leave It to Beaver
was in it not Leave It to Beaver but
there's no black and white movie it was
all black and white we was like the most
dangerous game where it's like those
teenagers and they land on the island
and like the guy starts haunting them
yeah so I've seen that
mst3k episode like probably a million
times so the guy or the woman that plays
the murderous guy's wife or girlfriend
or whatever she is that's the same
actress that played the mothership here
and I was like that's why she's [ __ ]
familiar because she was in [ __ ]
blood lust all right so it drove me
crazy until I looked at her [ __ ] IMDB
page I'm like it was a [ __ ] is this
woman is it like I said she had like a
huge [ __ ] career alright so we've
gone on and on about our three Christmas
movies hope you guys enjoyed this
Christmas retrospective triple feature
like I said all of these are on shudder
at the moment and two of them
are also on Joe Bob's last Drive in
which just shows the movie but then he
comes in with like facts and fun things
about the movie in like all kind of
little Christmas shenanigans so you
might want to go check that out he did
Jack Frost as well but we didn't have
time to review that one so maybe we'll
do that one next year
but yeah so have a happy holiday you
guys and we will see you next time